[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETER BARRON: You were
just saying Peter also used
to find time to
write about things
like the crunchiness
of crisps with the FT--
PETER BAZALGETTE: I got
my eye on this yogurt.
PETER BARRON: Yes,
exactly, so be careful.
But he certainly packs it in.
And it's great to
see this new book.
And I think the
number of people here
can attest that, in your
introduction to the book,
you say the empathy instinct
is an idea whose time has come.
And boy has it come.
And this was written before, I
think, Trump became president.
But it does seem to be
the spirit of the age.
So tell us how the book came
about in the first place.
How did you get into
the idea of empathy?
PETER BAZALGETTE:
So in a sentence,
empathy is usually
defined by people
as seeing something from
somebody else's point of view,
being able to put yourself
in somebody else's shoes.
And I was really
interested for two reasons.
First is, as you kindly
said in the introduction,
I've spent the last
four years fighting
the corner of public
funding of arts and culture.
And I got really
interested in whether we
made a good enough case
for public funding of arts
and culture.
And that said, well, what
are the benefits of arts
and culture?
And along with education, social
benefits, economic benefits,
there are what we call
intrinsic benefits, things
like identity and entertainment
and those sort of qualities.
And one of the phrases you came
up with is empathetic citizens.
Because if you think about
arts and popular culture--
think about movies, books.
And I go into some detail
about this in the book.
They are actually about
telling human stories that
enable you to put yourself
in somebody else's shoes,
see things from other
people's points of view.
So that was point of origin
number one, really, sort
of trying to define what the
benefits of arts and culture
are.
And I mean that broadly.
I'm not talking just
theater and visual arts.
I'm talking about broadcasting,
TV, film, in radio, and so on.
The second thing was I was
asked by the government
to chair something called a
Holocaust Memorial Foundation.
I don't know if you
know, we do actually
have a Holocaust
Memorial in this country.
You knew that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it's in [INAUDIBLE].
PETER BAZALGETTE: Ah, no.
AUDIENCE: There is one there.
PETER BAZALGETTE: You're
very knowledgeable.
There's something called the
Holocaust Center in Newark,
in Nottinghamshire, which is
actually set up by something
called the Smith family.
But no, we have a
small rock in Hyde Park
that not even most Jewish
people know is there.
And the prime minister,
David Cameron,
met a whole lot of
survivors of the camps
who were in their late
80s, early 90s who
go around the schools and
talk about the Holocaust.
And he realized they won't
be with us in 10 years time.
And he asked the
question, how are we going
to commemorate the Holocaust?
So I got to be
asked to chair this.
And we've got a
design competition
and we're building a
new Holocaust Memorial
in Victoria Tower Gardens,
so on and so forth.
But I got to meet
the survivors myself.
And you get to
think about what is
a society like that appears to
be apparently without empathy.
Now there's some
nuances to that.
But I'll just say
apparently without empathy.
And I got really
interested talking to them,
because in the first
chapter of the book,
I write about the
Holocaust in Germany,
the genocide in Armenia,
and the genocide in Rwanda.
And they have some
common themes to them.
But one of them is that society
seems to switch off its empathy
and become aggressive to people
who are different from you.
So those are the two origins.
PETER BARRON: And
you're got a quote here
from Obama on the back
of the book, which
is, "I think we're going
to have to talk more
about the empathy
deficit, the ability
to put ourselves in
somebody else's shoes."
So you're suggesting that--
Obama's suggesting too--
but there's a suggestion
that we're in a similar
era now as the era that
caused the Holocaust.
And a lot of people
are making comparisons
between the '30s and now.
Do you see a parallel?
PETER BAZALGETTE: I think that's
putting it a bit strongly.
We do have really healthy
democratic institutions.
But one of the things we've seen
in the last 12 to 18 months--
and I'd really be interested
to hear what your view is,
whatever your point of view,
is we've seen the language
of politics become--
well, you've been producing
political programs
on telly yourself, Peter,
for quite a few years
before you worked for Google.
So you'll have a view too.
But the language
of politics seems
to have become
coarser and angrier.
Personally I think it's to
do with post-credit crunch
and to do with the fact
that people feel poorer
and feel neglected.
Certainly we had
this experience,
did we not last year, whether
you voted to remain in the EU
or whether you voted
to leave the EU--
and I'd have a
pretty strong guess
of what the percentage
in this room would be,
but let's not go there.
We did feel a rather
divided country.
But no, I don't think
we're approaching that.
But I think we have to watch it.
And another thing I'm
really interested in
is what people in this room
think about the digital era.
I wrote a chapter in the book
called "The Digital Dystopia."
It's a given what the benefits
of the digital era are.
And you in this
room embody them.
But I think you're also aware
of what the downsides are,
of how you've had to deal
recently with Holocaust denial
and how that is
searched for, and what
your responsibilities
as an organization
are in that context
by the way, which
has been really interesting.
We were talking about
it just beforehand.
And so I am quite
concerned at the way
in which textual communication
is nonempathetic.
We spend a lot of our time,
when we talk to other people,
you have about eight
or 10 different regions
of your brain that help you
be empathetic to other people.
So we know this
because the MRI scanner
has been the big breakthrough
in the last 25 years.
The MRI scanner is allowing
us to map the human brain.
And it's not just for broken
legs from skiing holidays.
And we now know what the
different parts of the brain
are that do different things.
And so when you're having a
conversation with somebody,
you can read their face.
You can see what the
results of your words are.
You can see if
they're happy or sad.
That is an empathetic
communication,
unless of course you
happen to be psychopathic,
which none of you look
particularly psychopathic,
or you happen to
be, for instance,
on the autistic spectrum.
And there, in those
circumstances,
some of your empathy
circuit won't work
and you'll find it more
difficult to connect
with some of those things.
But textual communication
online is profoundly unemphatic.
And you don't see the
result of your words.
And cyberbullying and revenge
porn and all the other things
we know about, plus the fact
I'm rather intrigued at the way
that people who have what we
as a consensus would say has
a warped view-- let's
take Holocaust denial
as an example--
are now able to
connect with each other
in a way they never could
beforehand and reinforce
each other's prejudices.
And we get to a
position where we
tend to only talk to other
people who agree with us.
And part of empathy, putting
yourself in other people's
shoes, seeing other
people's point of views,
listening to different
points of view.
PETER BARRON: So can
we define empathy?
I mean, we have a lot
of engineers here,
a lot of scientists here.
So you say you can
measure empathy.
So first of all, can you
define what empathy is?
And how do you measure empathy?
PETER BAZALGETTE: So
you define empathy
as the ability to see
something from somebody else's
point of view, to put yourself
in somebody else's shoes.
There are two essential
elements to empathy.
One is cognitive empathy and
the other is emotional empathy.
Cognitive empathy
is the thing that
allows you to understand what
makes somebody else tick.
It doesn't necessarily make
you sympathetic to them.
It makes you understand.
I always like to give
the example of Iago
in "Othello" who understands
Othello perfectly, can play him
like a fiddle, but has
no sympathy for him.
In fact he uses
it sociopathically
and you might say
psychopathically.
So cognitive
empathy is that bit.
The emotional empathy
is your ability
to essentially experience the
emotions the other person is
having.
And that is a
position of sympathy.
So those are those two
elements of empathy
when you define it further.
There's another
point about empathy,
which is why I said there
was a nuance to my saying,
you know, it is the answer
to things like racism.
There are primatologists
who believe
that empathy is both
the answer to racism
but the cause of racism.
So this goes as follows.
There are really
good primatologists.
And the best one is a
guy called Franz de Waal
who wrote a book called
"The Age of Empathy."
And he's worked with
primates all his life.
And he's discovered that
primates have about 80%
of human empathy equipment.
And what he says is that
empathy is something
that can make you loyal to
your family, your group,
your own tribe, team
of football supporters,
group of football supporters,
and make you hostile to people
outside your group.
And that's quite a sort
of primeval influence
in the way we've grown up.
So he believes that
empathy is both
possibly the root of
racism, or one of them,
but also that it's the answer.
And that's why I love art's
and culture's role in this,
because that sort
of empathy that
enables you to see the
point of view of somebody
outside your group.
I always like-- can
I give an example?
PETER BARRON: Yes, please do.
PETER BAZALGETTE: I
like to give the example
of a play called "Red Velvet."
Did anybody ever see the
play "Red Velvet," which
was on at the Tricycle Theatre
in North London about three
or four years ago,
won a lot of awards?
Adrian Lester stared in it--
amazing story.
If I can have two
minutes on this?
PETER BARRON: Sure, sure.
PETER BAZALGETTE: There was a
black actor, American actor,
called Ira Aldridge who
came to the UK in the 1820s,
unbelievably.
And he was a very good actor.
And he was a jobbing
actor going around playing
in different places in different
capitals around Europe.
And he happened to
be in London when
Edmund Kean, who was the
big Shakespearean actor
of the time, was playing
Othello at Covent Garden.
And Edmund Kean was ill.
And so they put Ira Aldridge in
to play Othello in about 1825,
something like that.
There were massive
complaints from the cast
and from the public
at a black man being
put in the part of a black man.
And the play ends with him
putting on white makeup,
because the only parts he can
get are playing a white man.
And it's an incredibly
powerful play.
And if you are a white person in
a predominately white society,
it just begins to
help you put yourself
in the shoes of how
other people might feel,
who have a different skin color.
And so that's what I
mean about the power.
Now you could all give me
examples of books you've read,
or films you've seen that
have a similar effect.
Sometimes you wouldn't even
analyze it's happening.
But it's the extraordinary
power of arts and culture
to help you--
it's pro-empathetic,
and it's the opposite
of that thing about empathy
being the root of it.
PETER BARRON: Yes.
Let's talk a little bit
more about technology,
because you mentioned that it
can be an unempathetic place.
Emails can look very stark and
we don't pick up the signals
and so on.
But you actually
talk a little bit
in the book about the
effect that some aspects
of the internet and technology
have on people's brains.
You talked about kids in South
Korea who are gaming too much--
PETER BAZALGETTE: Oh, they're
talking about digital dementia.
PETER BARRON: Digital dementia--
PETER BAZALGETTE: I'm not
sure whether [INAUDIBLE].
PETER BARRON: --or the
effect that pornography
has on empathy, for example.
PETER BAZALGETTE:
Well the striatum
is the part of the brain
which is pleasure seeking.
I'm sure some of you know that.
And people who have a
prolonged pornography habit
have a very shrunken
striatum because it
takes more and more
extreme pornography
to please that part of your
brain which gives you pleasure.
Yes, so what are we,
15 years, should we
say, into a digital millennium?
PETER BARRON: Suppose so.
PETER BAZALGETTE: And
you guys are absolutely
at the forefront of it.
And on balance it is
a beneficial thing.
So I would never say
it's not beneficial.
But nothing is
purely beneficial.
PETER BARRON: You make that
very clear in the book.
PETER BAZALGETTE: Nothing's
purely beneficial.
And I don't think we've
begun to understand
what this always
on world of ours
is doing to our human relations.
There's some wonderful
research in America.
The power of empathy is
face to face communication.
And within a family,
the relationship
between parents and
children is all about face
to face communication.
We all know that.
You have families.
You are either in
families, you've
got children, or whatever.
And you also know that in a
more independent world where
children have their own
devices to entertain them,
they can make their own eating
decisions because of snack food
and so on, that actually
the time-- if you make time,
the time you get together as a
family is around a meal table,
if you still do that.
And it's so interesting
that people like Steve Jobs
made a point of doing
that and banning iPads
from his own children
for hours of the day
so he could get his
family together.
And there's research in
America now that says--
they've looked at
families together
in McDonald's and other places.
And the parents are
with their children,
but the parents are on
their mobile phones.
And they're not connecting
with their children.
And this is not me wailing.
And you know,
somebody accused me
in a review of the book
of being Mary Whitehouse.
And some of you are too young
to know who Mary Whitehouse was.
But some of you may not be.
But she was a sort of
campaigner against--
she was an extremely
methodistical campaign
against pornography
in the 1980s.
I'm not a Mary Whitehouse.
I generally think,
though, that we have not
begun to analyze what
the digital world is
doing to our human relations.
And we need to be
very aware of it.
And that was one of my
motives in writing the book.
So if we have an
empathy deficit,
what are your prescriptions
for doing something about it?
So I've divided the book
into different chapters
about different subjects.
One is indeed about early years.
And I call it the nurture
and nature of empathy.
The first 2 and 1/2 years
when the brain is forming
are the critical years
in children's lives.
You need to look at the
Romanian orphans locked away
without any human contact.
They didn't have
any ability even
to communicate let
alone anything else.
And that's a
critical [INAUDIBLE].
So I think that, for
instance, baby manuals
don't give it enough--
I mean, it is
mentioned these days.
I went back to the baby
manuals on the shelf
when my kids were young in
the late '80s, early '90s,
and I could find enema but
I couldn't find empathy
in the index.
So I think we've come along.
But I don't think it's
properly thought about
in how we connect
with small children
and how they grow up in
that critical period.
Then I've-- and we've covered it
already, the digital dystopia.
We need to think really
hard about how we maintain
human relations in
the digital era,
because parts of the digital
era militate against it.
But I've also written
about empathy and health.
So the evidence is that people
in the health care system
and in social care are
better, feel better,
and get better more
quickly if they feel they
are being treated with empathy.
But in a health system
which has finite resources
and infinite demand--
and you've seen all the
statistics in the last few days
about how many more people
they're trying to treat in A&E,
and you know about the
Mid Staff scandal of four,
five years ago.
So we need to think really
hard about entraining doctors,
nurses--
and care workers
in particular who
are particularly badly
paid and therefore
not very well trained--
is how we prepare them to
look after people properly.
Now this has a lot
of nuances to it.
If a doctor is so empathetic--
talking of cognitive
and emotional empathy--
if a doctor is so
empathetic he or she just
bursts into tears
every time they're
faced with a person who's
got cancer, what use is that?
They're useless.
So this is a very nuanced
and careful thing.
Anyway, I won't go on
about the health thing,
but we could discuss it further.
Then there's
another chapter I've
written about the
criminal justice system.
So we have a retributive system
based on Victorian ideals
where we think people
deserve to be punished.
And our recidivism
rate is hovering
around 50% that is reoffending.
In Norway it's 20%.
And we under-resource
our prisons.
And we don't connect with
people on a one to one basis
to help them get
better, to rehabilitate.
Many of them are
damaged individuals.
One in four people in
prisons were in care.
And that goes back to
what I was saying earlier.
Imagine what it's like
for children in care.
There's lots of
documentation about this,
by the way, about children
who didn't get the one to one
attention that we like
to give our children
or that we enjoyed
from our parents.
By the way, Simon Baron-Cohen,
the professor of psychology
at Cambridge who's done
brilliant work on empathy
and the different
parts of the brain,
because he's our leading expert
on autism and the autistic
spectrum and Asperger's.
And he calls it the
internal pot of gold
that your parents give you.
And I tell the story in the
book about James Fallon,
who is a neuroscientist
in America, who was doing
some research on psychopaths.
And as a control, he did brain
scans of some psychopaths
and brain scans of
his family members,
because he just wanted a
control to compare there.
And he found that his brain
was the most psychopathic,
showed the most
psychopathic trends.
And he then worked
out that he had
several traits of psychopathy.
And then he said, "Well why am
I not a fully blown psychopath?"
Because he had his mother's
influence when he was young.
And that's what
Simon Baron-Cohen
calls the internal pot of gold.
So anyway, there's the
thing about health,
there's the thing
about criminal justice.
And then there's
the pro-empathetic.
If you continue to promote
arts and popular culture--
and that includes public
service broadcasting, BBC--
PETER BARRON: Talk more
in-depth about that.
So we're talking about
our internal pot of gold.
And you're really saying
that the arts fill up
your internal pot of gold
and keep it healthy, yes?
So how does that work?
PETER BAZALGETTE: Well, I
mean, does anybody here--
I mean, you may find radio
rather old fashioned.
But does anybody here listen
to "The Archers" on Radio 4?
PETER BARRON: Yeah, come on.
PETER BAZALGETTE:
Yeah, it's one bloke--
one bloke.
Surely some of you do.
Even if it's a podcast
you must listen to it.
Anyway, the point
is "The Archers--"
I'm just going to
take one example.
"The Archers" is a publicly
funded radio soap opera
that you're a huge fan of sir.
You will be able
to tell us, it had
a major storyline
last year, listened to
by millions of people, about
violence within a marriage,
with a very well worked
out storyline going on
over a long period of time.
And that made many
people understand
what that phenomenon is, how to
report it, how to deal with it,
and what it's like for
people involved in it.
But I could tell you about
"Eastenders" and "Coronation
Street."
PETER BARRON: Well
actually "Big Brother,"
and you mentioned
this in the book,
because Peter was that the
man behind "Big Brother" who
brought it to Britain.
PETER BAZALGETTE: So most
people blame me for that.
PETER BARRON: Over many years.
And it's certainly not
been uncontroversial.
And "The Daily Mail"
and others have--
PETER BAZALGETTE: We
love "The Daily Mail."
PETER BARRON: --attacked
you in strong language.
But actually you
make an argument
that, particularly
in the early days,
that "Big Brother" actually
had an empathetic benefit
to the nation.
PETER BAZALGETTE: Well, look,
I don't want to overstate this.
You'll get me into trouble.
It's an entertainment
show made for money
with commercials around
it, invented by a Dutchman
who became very wealthy
on the back of it.
And so let me not
sort of make out
that it was some sort
of religious crusade.
It was not.
It had an interesting side
effect, let me put it that way.
You put 12 people in the house--
I mean, it's part of
mainstream television now.
There are lots of
different programs doing it
in different ways.
In the UK, it turned out
the people who voted--
and this is a
popularity contest--
people who voted were looking
for authentic decent people
that they approved
of, who they felt
behaved in a decent manner.
We have some sort of--
In America, it's
quite different.
The winners of "Big
Brother" in America
are always the people who
played the competition hardest
and cheated and backstabbed.
They would get voted first.
So just shows you how
different countries
have different cultures--
interesting.
But in the UK we had
a winner, a gay man
in an early series, which I
think was quite significant.
And a gay woman in the first
series was the runner up.
We had a winner who had Tourette
syndrome, who was apparently
foul mouthed.
It turned out to be somebody
who was a completely
charming bloke, but had this
compulsion, this mental tick
as it were.
And the public discovered
behind that foul mouth
was a very, very nice--
and we had a transsexual.
And these were all
people who were somewhat
stereotyped and demonized by
the tabloid newspapers when
they first appeared.
And all I would say
about that-- and I
don't want to make, as I
say, too many claims for it.
It's just an aside--
is that it did
show that when you
tell a human story in the
arena of popular culture,
you quite often get a
perspective about somebody
you previously
would have dismissed
in a stereotypical way.
PETER BARRON: Right,
good, thank you.
Let's go to the audience
for some questions.
SPEAKER: I've got
a microphone here
if anyone would like to ask.
PETER BARRON:
Gosh, No questions.
Oh, we've got one over here.
Excellent.
PETER BAZALGETTE: Mic's coming.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: So I am
particularly concerned
about this issue, this
topic, and out of it
the switch, the empathy switch.
PETER BAZALGETTE: You mean
switching it on it on and off?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PETER BAZALGETTE:
Yeah, of course.
AUDIENCE: Of course.
And I'm thinking, and I've
been thinking about this
and how individuals
are actually choosing
to switch their
empathy off as it
suits them on various examples.
And it happens for most of
us on a daily basis, I think.
If and when we go
to the supermarket,
it's as simple as that.
So I'd like to address the
questions of the public
if you don't mind.
How many of you think
they love animals?
Can you raise your hand?
OK.
How many--
PETER BAZALGETTE: This is only
for human beings by the way.
AUDIENCE: And how many
of you are meat-eaters?
PETER BAZALGETTE:
Oh that's a toughie.
Go on.
Keep going.
AUDIENCE: I don't want
to hijack this topic.
PETER BAZALGETTE: No, it's fine.
It's fine.
AUDIENCE: But I'm thinking
that it's a paradox,
don't you think, to say and
think that you love animals,
but at the same time
to eat their bodies
and accept that they
are being killed in--
PETER BAZALGETTE:
Are you a vegetarian?
AUDIENCE: I am vegan.
PETER BAZALGETTE:
You're a vegan.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PETER BAZALGETTE:
Good, excellent.
AUDIENCE: Well I am supposed
to stand to my beliefs.
PETER BAZALGETTE: No, no,
I'm respecting your beliefs
and I'm very pleased
you've made them.
I don't want to
interrupt you by the way.
AUDIENCE: Right, right.
So I consider this
as being an exercise,
a daily exercise in everyone
of switching their empathy off.
Because if we would turn
our empathy back on,
then we wouldn't choose that
chicken or that piece of lamb
or beef in the supermarket.
And that's a conscious choice.
And I think that most of
us do not think about it.
Or even worse, we choose
not to think about it.
And going forward, having
this exercise, daily exercise
of switching our empathy off,
doesn't that make us more--
and I'm just giving one example.
There are others.
Doesn't that make us more prone
to listening to what society
dictates to us and being
part to other trends
where the empathy is
switched on and off,
and especially off, because
we already have the exercise.
We're already capable.
And this is kind of
what I think makes
some people more prone to it.
PETER BAZALGETTE: Good
that's a very, really good--
no, it's a really interesting
and good challenge.
AUDIENCE: What do you think?
PETER BAZALGETTE: Well let
me put an alternative point
of view to it.
AUDIENCE: Yes please.
PETER BAZALGETTE: And thank
you very much for the question.
Our ability to switch
our empathy off
is what keeps us sane.
There's something called
emotional burnout.
If your empathy is
always switched on,
you watch the television news,
see what's happening in Syria,
you'd go mad with grief.
And you'd cease to
operate as a human being.
Yes, no, tell me I'm wrong.
Go ahead.
No, have the mic back.
AUDIENCE: But that's
the emotional empathy
that we all have to
switch off, isn't it?
It's not the cognitive one.
PETER BAZALGETTE: Well, it's
an interplay of the two.
It's an interplay of the two.
Both operate in different ways.
And doctors have to have a
very subtle understanding
of how you connect those
two and how you use them.
But all I'm saying is generally,
that's how we operate.
And it's very interesting
in news, which you've worked
in Peter, how it works that--
when David Cameron
was prime minister
and the Syrian
refugees were flooding
across the
Mediterranean, he'd seen
the research that
said people were
very worried about immigration.
Which by the way they were
when the Kindertransport Jewish
children were trying--
were trying to get the Jewish
children in the late 1930s.
Similarly there
were people saying
we can't take all these people.
We don't want these people.
Who are there?
They have nothing to do with us.
We find it very difficult to
empathize with a population
but very easy to empathise
with an individual story.
Alan Kurdi, which I
write about in the book,
was the little boy, tragically
3 and 1/2 in trainers face
down drowned on the beach.
And Cameron then
agreed-- it turned out
to be 350 we heard
the other day.
But he agreed to
take, I think, 12,000.
And public sentiment changed.
There was empathy switched off
and then switched on again.
It's actually completely
natural for you
to switch your
empathy on and off.
It's a completely
natural mechanism.
If you walked down
the street and stopped
at every person who may need
help, you'd never get to work.
And if you didn't get to work,
you wouldn't-- because you
wouldn't be--
so that's a slightly-- it may
sound slightly absurd example,
but we constantly
switch it on and off.
My argument is, we need to be--
and you're about to tell me
I'm wrong by the
way, but anyway.
But my argument is that we need
to be much more aware of it
and enhance it for
better public discourse,
for better public services
and all the rest of it,
but to appreciate the
subtleties and the nuance.
Now have one more go at me.
Go on.
AUDIENCE: But then
where's the moral?
Where's the ethics?
I mean if it's OK
to switch empathy
on and off between good and evil
and you're always oscillating--
PETER BAZALGETTE: No, no, no,
but empathy is an instinct.
It's not a moral code.
What I said earlier
was that empathy
operates with moral
code, and with a sense
of reciprocity and fairness.
And all those things
have to interrelate.
It's not the same
thing as a moral code.
AUDIENCE: It's not.
PETER BAZALGETTE: That
is a separate thing--
AUDIENCE: It's not.
PETER BAZALGETTE:
--separate construct.
AUDIENCE: But it impacts it--
PETER BAZALGETTE:
And by the way,
you have a different moral
code to me, because yes, I
love dogs, but yes, I eat meat.
And in your eyes, that
is, as you've made clear,
a contradictory position.
But it's one I can live with.
PETER BARRON: I think we
should give others a chance.
Let's move on.
PETER BAZALGETTE: But
they're fantastic questions
and really good challenges,
really interesting.
PETER BARRON: Next
question over here.
AUDIENCE: I might actually
hop in and then go
there, very prosaic.
A lot of my friends think
very similarly to me.
So we get together and
we say the same things
and we agree with
each other and we
think it's fabulous,
which means we're not
exposed to these conflicting
views and opinions.
How do I go about doing that?
What's the best way?
PETER BAZALGETTE: That's
a really good question.
I think the answer's
in this room, isn't it?
I mean, the very thing that
I said in the digital era
where we're tending to connect
with people we agree with,
we have the ability to connect
with people we disagree with.
And that, of course,
is the essence
of democratic discourse.
Are we a more polarized
society now than we
were five or 10 years ago?
PETER BARRON: Well I
think the Brexit thing
and what's happened
in the States
suggests we are more polarized.
PETER BAZALGETTE: But
you know something,
maybe we were
polarized all along
but we never just
put the question.
So we went through a
polarizing experience.
Maybe people felt
that way already.
So you could say that the number
of places that voted to remain
remind me of the
English Civil War.
In the English Civil
War in the 17th century,
various cities were for
the king and various cities
were for Cromwell.
And if you look at the
cities that were for remain,
London, Brighton, Bristol,
Oxford, Cambridge, Manchester,
Newcastle just,
these are all places
with sunrise industries, strong
higher education, growth, jobs,
strong economies basically,
and modern economies.
And if you look at the places
that voted massively to leave,
they're depressed.
When you live in
the London bubble,
we haven't thought about
that very much, have we?
I hadn't thought
about it enough.
PETER BARRON: Yeah.
I mean it definitely
works both ways.
We talk about empathy.
Of course the Syrian
kids on the beach,
that provoked a huge amount
of empathy among people.
But it's harder, perhaps,
to demonstrate empathy
for the people
living in Doncaster
who feel that they
are being overwhelmed
by refugees or immigrants coming
into their towns and so on.
So I think it's
kind of important,
isn't it, to be empathetic
in all directions.
And I think going
back to news, I
think the point about a
good way of doing journalism
is to take news from
all different sides
and expose those rather than
drive one view all the time.
PETER BAZALGETTE:
And politicians
have to listen in the
end to be successful.
Question whether the current
president of the United States
is a listener.
I think probably not.
PETER BARRON: Next question.
PETER BAZALGETTE: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
How do you think we
should apply empathy,
both cognitive and
sympathetic, to people
who are very far away from
our own political opinions
and standpoints?
I feel that it's very
easy, especially when
you take someone who's kind
of on the polar opposite
of yourself, it's
very easy to think,
oh, they're being deluded
or they're just pure evil
or something like that.
But how should we actually
approach these people?
Should we see their opinions as
being divorced from themselves
as their fundamental nature?
Because at the same time you
could also use this argument
to kind of take people
who most of us would think
are quite evil,
bad people and just
say, oh, that's simply a
political opinion they had.
So how does that [INAUDIBLE]?
PETER BAZALGETTE: That's
a really good question.
I was talking earlier
about the interplay
of empathy and ethics.
So there are things
that unite us,
even people we have very strong
political disagreements about--
the rule of law, property,
the ethics of free speech,
a democratic society.
There are various
things we subscribe to.
And so there is a
distinction between people
who come within our generally
agreed ethics and people
who are way beyond it.
There is a dilemma nowadays--
and I talk about it in the
chapter on criminal justice.
There's a dilemma today because
the old statement of, say,
the police or religious
leaders, such and such
was pure evil is
not good enough.
Personally, you know, I'm
not actually religious
and I don't believe in
something called the devil.
But I think the devil was a
way of articulating people
who lacked empathy,
who were psychopathic,
who were not able to have
any emotional empathy
for other people.
And the question is,
well, if they have a brain
malfunction, how can you, in
any way, hold them responsible?
And the answer is, one, you need
to protect society from them.
So you need to
lock people up who
are a danger to the
rest of society.
But two, for society's
own good, you
need to have a
principle of being
responsible for your
actions, even if you are
suffering from a malfunction.
So all of those things
say that if people
are within what
is legal, what is
agreed as being the ethics
of a democratic society
that we subscribe to, then
they may disagree with us,
but we should listen to them
and they're a legitimate part
of the democratic discourse.
If they're beyond that, if
they are murdering people
or if they're involved in,
say, racial hatred, race crime,
that's something else.
And that's a distinction.
PETER BARRON: Yes,
but there are people
who would argue that
you should even be
empathetic towards terrorists.
I mean, there's a
fascinating interview
with Ian Paisley Jr. on the
radio the other day talking
about Martin McGuinness.
And it was a masterclass
in empathy toward someone
who used to be the commander
in chief of the IRA.
And people like Jonathan
Powell, for example,
say in the end you've got
to talk to all terrorists.
PETER BAZALGETTE:
Quoted in the book.
PETER BARRON: You've
got to talk to ISIS.
So could you be empathetic
towards at least the causes
of ISIS if not the
individuals themselves?
PETER BAZALGETTE:
Well, in the end,
you settle disputes
of that sort,
Northern Ireland, by talking.
Personally I believe peace
came to Northern Ireland
because the young hotheads
driven by testosterone
had children and then indeed
grandchildren in the case
of some of them, Gerry Adams.
And I think they wanted a
future for their children
and their grandchildren.
And I think they changed
their point of view.
And I think their
testosterone levels went down.
But yes, in the end you have to
talk to terrorists for peace.
But that doesn't mean,
does it, that you
endorse their terrorism,
which is a different thing.
But I do quote Jonathan
Powell's quote there.
In fact it was Hugh
Gaitskell who said that--
he was referring
to the independence
leaders in British colonies
in Africa in the 1950s.
He said it always
ends up with drinks
in the Dorchester, which is
a similar way of Jonathan
Powell's statement.
I don't think I perfectly
answered your question,
but I've tried to address it.
PETER BARRON: Next question.
AUDIENCE: So it seems to me that
we tend to shut down empathy
in response to fear.
To what extent does the
evidence bear this out
as being generally true?
And if it does, what can
we do about it to stop--
you know, it seems to be very
easy to stir up fear and get
people to react,
to sort of ignore
their sort of empathy instincts.
PETER BAZALGETTE: Yeah, just
unpack fear or examples,
what you're talking about.
AUDIENCE: For example, sort
of tabloids stirring up
panic over immigration,
for example,
or Nigel Farage talking about
health tourists coming here
to get HIV treatment,
that sort of thing.
It seems often some
politicians will deliberately
play on our fears
in order to get
us to shut down our empathy.
How do we combat that?
How do we get people to be
empathic in the face of fear?
PETER BAZALGETTE: It's
such a good question.
Do you personally-- sorry, just
could you check the mic back?
Sorry.
Do you personally feel--
because the examples you give
are to do with media
representation or media
quoting people in
a particular way.
Do you feel that
our public discourse
has got more extreme
in the last five years?
Is that your sense?
How do you feel?
AUDIENCE: I feel that
it has, but I'm not sure
whether it's really true
or whether it's just
my perception, that I'm noticing
sort of frequency bias type
thing, that I'm noticing
more examples of things
that sort of trigger me.
PETER BAZALGETTE:
So here, there's
no perfect answer
to your question.
But here's a couple of points.
One is, I said that you
have to link empathy
not only to ethics but a sense
of reciprocity and fairness.
If you said that the British
health service, enormously
under pressure as it is,
was opened to all comers
and anybody could
come here and have
a child in a maternity
hospital or get any treatment
they want from
anywhere in the world,
that would be patently
absurd because we simply
don't have the resources.
And you might say,
actually, we are
going to prioritize the
people in this country who
pay the taxes that fund
it in the first place.
And that's fairness.
And so that's part
of the answer.
And I can't tell you
where the line's drawn
or what the perfect balance is.
I just acknowledge that those
are different factors in it.
But in terms of extremism
or extreme representation,
and indeed
misrepresentation, now we're
coming to the
dreaded phrase fake
news, which is, I
think, a phrase that you
think about in this building
very often actually.
I personally think that we need
trusted and reliable sources
of news and information to
let the democratic society
function.
I would observe-- it may sound
like I'm going off of one here,
but bear with me.
I would observe that most of
those sources of impartial news
or news that tries
to be impartial
would have to be subsidized
because they're not profitable.
By which I mean the BBC
has the license fee.
"The Guardian" loses money.
"The Times" loses money.
"Huffington Post" has
been bought by somebody
and is maintained, but
I don't think on its own
it's profitable.
It's just part of a
bigger online presence.
Sky News loses money.
PETER BARRON: But it is the case
that stronger flavors are more
commercially viable.
So you see Fox News
and so on where--
PETER BAZALGETTE: And Fox News
with its latest news on Sweden
that the president of the United
States was able to rely on.
So what am I saying?
This is not just a sort of
motherhood and apple pie
answer, because I tell
you what I'm going to say.
I'm going to say that those
sources of news and information
are more important
today, where we
are today in the
digital era, than they
were 20 or 30 years ago when
they pretty well the only news
outlets.
And I think so far
they've been very
poor at promoting themselves
in the digital universe.
And you may say that search
has a part to play in this too.
And that is a massive
challenge to your organization.
How do you have a
legitimate source of search
that has veracity?
PETER BARRON: But we would say
that the diversity of views
that are now available compared
with 20 or 30 years ago
when you might have had one or
two or three sources of news
are infinitely wider.
But of course the danger
of the filter bubble
is real in some circumstances.
PETER BAZALGETTE: Exactly.
So we've got some challenges.
So those would be the two
points I'd make anyway.
One, don't forget that there
has to be a sense of fairness.
And two, we need to
think very carefully
about how we do report.
And nobody is saying
you can't report
a speech of Nigel Farage's that
some people may find extreme.
We're simply saying, can you
go to a pretty prominent source
that analyzes the claims and
says, are they true or not,
without fear or favor.
That's terribly important.
SPEAKER: I think we have
time for two more questions.
There's one back here.
AUDIENCE: What about
the feeling of guilt
if we have the empathy
switch turned off,
but we would kind
of like to be on,
how to deal with that feeling?
It's something that I
personally struggle with.
I'm sure other people as well.
So what's your opinion on that?
PETER BAZALGETTE: Can
you, not necessarily
about your own
experience, can you
give an example,
just one example?
Make one up if you like.
You don't have to
talk about what
happens to you in
your own personal life
necessarily, but give an
example of a situation
where you're conscious of
you're not being very empathetic
and you're a bit
guilty about it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, an example,
a friend ends up at hospital,
and you would really want
to visit him or do something
for him or her, but
you just don't feel it
and you would like to feel it.
PETER BAZALGETTE: You
could spend all your time
visiting people in hospital.
And the point I
made earlier, you
wouldn't be earning a living.
You'd be starving.
Your family would be starving.
You'd be exhausted.
And you'd end up not being
very sympathetic to the people
you're confronted with.
So where is the balance?
You need a balance, don't you?
But in terms of
friends in hospital,
I'd suggest to you if
they're a really good friend,
you would visit then.
You would make time.
Do you know something,
the very fact
that you pose the question to
yourself hugely encourages me.
And I think the question
you've asked yourself
is the answer to your question.
PETER BARRON: Do
the right thing.
PETER BAZALGETTE: Yeah.
But the fact you've
asked the question--
PETER BARRON: It
means you know--
PETER BAZALGETTE: --is
fantastically encouraging--
PETER BARRON: --you
know [INAUDIBLE].
PETER BAZALGETTE: --because
you're conscious of the issue.
That's fantastic.
AUDIENCE: So you talk about
kind of the power of one
to one, empathy, and how arts
are really useful for this.
And we've had a lot of changes
with sort of the advent of VR
and the ability to place
yourself with someone
without having to
physically be with them,
and sort of the scale
that that can generate.
So what's your view on some
of these sort of VR stories,
like the UN Syrian story
and the power that that
has to sort of spread empathy?
PETER BAZALGETTE: Yes,
I've written, briefly,
about virtual reality
in the book actually,
because it is quite interesting.
If you take the terrible
conditions in that refugee
camp in Calais, the two
dimensional film of it
repeated again and
again on the news
pretty well gets you to
switch your empathy off,
as we were discussing earlier.
But if you can put a headset on
and you can explore it and take
decisions to turn
left or right and see
what you see and
interact with it,
which is perhaps the crucial
word, it is quite powerful.
So there are people
doing work with the UN
at the moment who are
very interested in how
VR may be a very empathetic
medium, and a more empathetic
medium than we've met before.
And there's even a
marketing organization
in New York that is
attempting to use that quality
to get us to connect more with
brand and commercial messages.
So it's a really interesting
question you asked.
And people are looking at it.
It's potentially very powerful.
PETER BARRON: Great,
thank you very much indeed
Peter, wonderful stuff,
fascinating stuff.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER BAZALGETTE: Can I just
thank everybody for coming?
I mean, it's lovely to see some
many people and lovely to have
such fantastic questions and
so engaging with the subject.
So thank you very much indeed.
I really appreciate it.
PETER BARRON: Thank you.
And I think you're able to
hang on for a little bit
to sign some books.
PETER BAZALGETTE: Yeah, sure.
PETER BARRON: So if
you've got a book,
please form an orderly queue.
Thank you very much indeed.